if you look at these cabinet appointees
they were selected for a reason and that
is the deconstruction of the
administrative state and if you before
he left the Trump administration former
adviser Steve Bannon famously vowed to
deconstruct what he called the
administrative state that collection of
bureaucrats agencies and unelected
rulemaking bodies whose decrees govern
more and more of our lives cutting
regulations and policies that come not
directly from Congress but from
administrators who decide say that the
FCC has the ability to regulate the
Internet under rules originally created
for public utilities president Trump's
appointee to the Supreme Court Neel
Gorsuch is a critic of the
administrative state to questioning the
legal validity of rules laid out by
bureaucracies and some of his best-known
rulings and so far many of the
president's picks at places such as the
FCC the FDA the EPA and the Department
of Education seem to be doing just that
I view it as the leading threat to civil
liberties of our era I recently sat down
with Columbia Law School's Phillip
hamburger to discuss whether the
administrative state is a threat to
freedom and representative government
he's one of the leading critics of the
administrative state and the author most
recently of the administrative threat in
Phillip Aaron Berger thank you for
talking thank you for having me here
let's start by defining administrative
law in the administrative state what
does it do and where does it come from
all right so administrative power can be
understood in many different ways some
people use the phrase to describe all
government power in the executive and
that's rather too broad it's
indiscriminate
I use the phrase to describe what I was
really sort of extra legal rulemaking an
adjudication exercise of power to bind
Americans to control Americans not
through the pathways set up by the
Constitution name the acts of Congress
and acts of the court but through other
edicts typically from agencies in your
recent book is administrative law
unlawful you like in the practice of
administrative law to off-road driving
and you're right the problem examined
here is thus not where the government is
heading but how it drives to leave the
roads laid out by the Constitution can
be exhilarating at least for those in
the drive
all the same it is unlawful and
dangerous so administrative power it's
not Congress doesn't make a law and then
it gets implemented that's not an
administrative power Congress passes a
law and then it you know that says we
want clean air and then the EPA says ok
in order to implement that law we're
coming up with all of these different
aspects right the the danger is in what
the agencies do Congress certainly has
power to enact all sorts of laws
regulating us and so this is not
argument against regulation we can
debate the merits of particular
regulations but rather it's an argument
against having the executive or
independent agencies which are more or
less a part of the executive make rules
that bind us in the same manner as laws
enacted by Congress but they're not
subject to the same kind of public
discussion or vote you know or so is the
administrative state bad because it ends
the separation of powers because the
executive branch gets to make more and
more decisions or or maybe end or it's
bad because the rules can't really be
you know they're implemented in a non
democratic or non representative what I
view it as the leading threat to civil
liberties of our era we have a republic
we still have a republic established by
the Constitution meaning we have a
system of government in which our laws
are made by the folks we elect and these
laws are enforced by judges and juries
in the courts but we have within that an
administrative state a state that acts
really by mere command not through law
and that adjudicates not in courts with
judges and juries but through its own
tribunals the freedoms that parallel
government that worries me you know what
our leading examples for you or you know
the most current telling examples of the
administrative state right so one can
find this in most agencies agencies get
a loose instruction from Congress for
example make era clean and then the
agency will define clean and make a host
of rules requiring how we should
regulate our lives and our businesses
and our farms and the rest these rules
are not enacted by Congress and that's
why this is really some a Liberties
problem we should be able to live under
made by the folks we elect that's the
whole point of having a republic but
well to think about something like the
Clean Air Act or whatever I mean you
know these are massive laws and what how
do you answer critics who say well of
course you're gonna give you know you're
gonna kind of push a lot of the
responsibility for actually writing up
the rules that implement the goals of
the law to bureaucrats cuz I mean you
know what I don't know you know who's
your least favorite congressman you
don't want him defining pollution for
you right there's a there's a danger of
error in Congress there are perhaps 500
sources of error and Congress and
there's only one source of error perhaps
in an agency but in fact that makes it
all the more desirable to have this done
in Congress because there's also a
chance that the folks will get it right
whereas in an agency there's great
danger of a single point of view being
imposed that isn't really responsive to
the people the reality is that we had a
revolution and we establish a
constitution as a great experiment in
human history to see if we can govern
ourselves and to create an alternative
system of government which looks more
Menorca coal which is a matter of almost
military command it's really a profound
departure and a denial of everything we
expect when we seek equal voting rights
in the rest when you know in looking at
administrative the the administrative
state or the rise of administrative law
a lot of people point back to a 1984
case I went to the Supreme Court that
was Chevron versus what was that the
National Resources Defense Council or
could you explain that and is that what
is that the kind of original sin of the
administrative State oh it's by no means
the original sin it's just one of many
I'm afraid but it is what it is a type
of deference of judicial deference to
agencies agencies acquire lawmaking
power by Express authority from Congress
but sometimes Congress doesn't give them
authority nonetheless they take it to
make rules where they say that the
statute is ambiguous and therefore in
order to interpret it they have to fill
in the gaps as it were and that's what
shut the Chevron case really allows and
systematizes and the awkwardness of all
of this is that with the government
where the government is a party to a
case the judges when they defer
to the agency's interpretation of a
statute are in fact adopting the legal
position of one of the parties in the
case before them in other words the
judges become systematically biased it's
really a genuine Civil Liberties problem
because our procedural rights are the
bulk of the bill of rights and primary
amongst these is due process of law and
jury rights now when a case that's
decided by Administrative Tribunal comes
up before a court what does it judge do
the judge will defer to the agency in
the facts and defer to the agency on the
law under cases like Chevron and the
result is systemic bias even in the
courts
so the problem isn't just the agency but
the courts themselves is the biased
always towards kind of is it always
towards the the experts so you know is
it a part of the cult of the experts or
is it results-driven or is it both for
the courts I suspect it's principled in
some secondary sense not high principles
of due process and jury rights which are
thrown aside but principled in the sense
that they don't feel competent to make
these decisions themselves and they'd
rather leave the interpretation to the
experts the awkwardness is that they're
thereby allowing agencies to make law
and the judges themselves are abandoning
their independent judgment and in fact
being biased in favor of the government
so in something like the Chevron case
would you have prefer to win a better
outcome and for the courts to say you
know what we we can't interpret this but
neither should the agency and they
should somehow kick it back to Congress
to say if you want clean air you got to
be more specific in the way you write
laws there's no need for the judges to
defer to the agency's if they cannot
find meaning in the statute yes they
should just let it go what is the in in
one of the things that Trump's Secretary
of Education Betsy DeVos has done is
she's she's changing the definition of a
of an policy that came out of the Office
of Civil Rights in the Department of
Education a Dear Colleague letter that
you know suggested a lower level of
proof for cases of assault sexual
assault on campus the creation of
hostile workplaces is that the type of
administrative law that's problematic
right so that's yet another mode of
making rules by
by agencies at least in a formal room in
much of the rulemaking the agencies will
follow various administrative procedures
to create the role very often in fact
increasingly one finds administrative
powers an evasion even of administrative
limits on rulemaking and guidance falls
into that category there the agencies
will interpret their own rules and issue
mere guidance it's a gentle hint a
governance by by a wink and a nod not
even by rulemaking so what what is
driving this if it's not specific legal
rulings or rather they kind of are
mileposts
towards a vaster and vaster
administrative state who's setting that
direction that we seem to be we keep
driving - Gary Lawson a scholar at
Boston University has noted the rise and
rise at the Ministry of State the
administrative power always seems to
expand whether under Democrats
Republicans and I think the reason for
this is one has to think of
administrative power really is an
evasion of regular pathways first
invasion of constitutional pathways for
making law and adjudicating and then
even an invasion of administrative
pathways you get ever less formal modes
of binding Americans of commanding
Americans and telling them what to do
this is just the natural progress I
think of power always to escape its
limits well you've made an argument
though also our rather it's a
provocative coincidence or maybe not a
coincidence but that as as the the vote
expands to include more and more people
who are seen as lesson let maybe perhaps
less and less deserving of the vote or
less and less knowledgeable so right at
the time where people without property
get in franchise women blacks etc their
votes count for less and less because
the administrative state is calling all
the shots is there you know is that just
a coincidence or is there something more
severe there's a very disturbing linkage
between these two developments if you
think of the main two developments of
American law since the Civil War one has
been equal voting rights and the other
one has been in the Ministry of State
and so are they connected maybe they are
but I think happened was that as we got
increasing
suffrage for blacks for women and then
not just a formality but as a reality in
the 1960s the knowledge class those
persons who felt as a attachment to
their abstract academic knowledge rather
than to local hierarchies of
representative government became very
disturbed by the results they were happy
to see equal voting but they didn't like
the results and Woodrow Wilson is quite
explicit about this he says it's very
difficult for progressive performers to
persuade persons who are not of the
older stocks as he puts it
and then he specifies the persons who
are for example Irishmen Germans and
Negroes now this racist element I think
is not central but actually is driving
this is a disdain for governance by the
unwashed masses and I I assume there
must be records of this but the
progressive must have been when women
get to vote and then they vote for
warren g harding it's like what were we
thinking
right because no progressive wanted him
in a you know a thousand miles within
the white house right there's a very
disturbing degree to which
administrative power tends to increase
fifteen years or so after each expansion
of suffrage 1870 blacks got the right to
vote 1880s get the first federal agency
1920 women get the right to vote 1930s
we got a further expansion of the
Minister of State in 1960 and so forth
well can I ask so did the administrative
state expand if you look at the Civil
Rights Acts and Voting Rights Acts of
the mid sixties when Ronald Reagan hits
did the administrative state expand
under him it expands really in the 1970s
so it's not long after the tumult of the
60s we get administrative state and
therefore more orderly mode of
governance that suits the knowledge
class I don't think there was a
conspiracy here it's just the natural
progress of events but it constitutes
really one of the profound a profound
bait-and-switch of a sort that we really
need to take notice of the
administrative threat is the greater if
the greater the administrative power is
the greatest threat to equal voting
rights because it allows you the
formality of electing your
representatives but takes away
administrative power and places it and
safer hands as it were our people are
even people who support the
administrative state
openly are they actually are they kind
of in in the same way that there are
mostly Fairweather federalists people
say you know what I want to do volve
power down to a lower set of government
that's closer to the place where the
rules are taking place etc very few
people are principled Federalists the
Republicans and Democratic parties will
switch sides on states rights or
devolving power whenever it suits the
outcome they want even John C Calhoun
was a fair-weather Federalist our
state's writer is that true also of the
administrative state it may be true I
think a large number of politicians
I haven't surveyed it I don't I don't
really know but one suspects so
certainly Republic you know the
Democrats are not the only supporters of
the administrative state most
Republicans probably are too the real
division isn't politics nor even
ultimately race although I do think
minorities get terribly hurt by the
administrative state and it's a
modernizing tendencies the real division
is class the knowledge class appreciates
the sort of power that's exercised by
people well-liked themselves and that's
less obvious to persons who aren't
members of that class or who are
minorities that get hurt by the
administrative state do you take Donald
Trump and obviously it was Bannen who
famously said he wants to deconstruct
the administrative state Trump is an
interesting case then because in many
ways he you know he's the second coming
of Andrew Jackson he's a very commanding
person who want you know he even wants
the NFL to change its policies based on
his you know blood sugar levels at a
given moment is he do you think is he
good - is he good on his promise to kind
of get rid of the administrative state
or hold it back
well we've yet to see thus far there
have been great many rules that have
been overturned but overturning rule one
way or another isn't really the point
this is not an argument for the merits
opponent regulation another the real
test will be will he cut back on the
power the types of power that could be
used by either party for good or for ill
but in the long term for great ill
because it undermines
constitutional system well adobe can you
lay a wager there do you are you
confident or are you optimistic I think
the idea I have no idea but I look
forward to seeing it'll be interesting
well that's that's a cop-out well well
select what I am a lawyer and I place
trust although many politicians can do
good things I place trust actually in
litigation and that's different right I
mean in in terms of some critics of the
administrative state and charles murray
the writer and scholar at the American
Enterprise Institute has written a lot
about this and he has called for a kind
of judicial attack or using the courts
to gum up the ability of agencies to
pass laws but you critique him in in
your in your writing you say that he's
less interested in the process and more
in the outcome is that accurate
I think Charles Murray is very worried
about the economic costs of regulation
and that's a different sort of argument
my argument is this is of a liberties
problem this really guts our civil
liberties and you take procedural rights
for example these used to be guarantees
against government now these are just
another option for government in acting
against us because it can act through
the courts with due process of juries or
simply evade that so I I think unlike
Murray I would treat this as a civil
liberties issue and that means careful
systematic litigation not gumming up the
works as it were I think a more
straightforward attack on this a civil
liberties issue is worth the point do
you think is Neel Gorsuch truly a is is
he the you know the Deconstructor of the
administrative state on the Supreme
Court I have no idea I my only hope for
him and all of his colleagues is that
they will adhere to the Constitution
including due process and jury rights
and the right to independent judgement
from a judge all of which are guaranteed
by the Constitution so you're quite mad
aren't you mad we didn't saint
[Laughter]
you a lot of the you know your work is
informed by this and obviously even this
conversation there's very much of a high
aqui and a Friedrich Hayek strain in
your thought in terms of insisting on
rules that are visible and kind of
simple and and everybody has to play by
them as well as the idea of seeking
knowledge I mean I love the idea it's
kind of a reverse of Hayekian idea of
the dispersion of knowledge you want to
have ignorant it disperses widely as
possible if the ability it's better to
have 500 people making bad decisions
than just one if because you can counter
it more effectively I guess but what is
your relationship to someone like Hayek
or you're a kind of legal philosophy
right so I actually had never thought of
myself as a Hayek in although I'm
flattered by the thought I confess I'm
just a lawyer and well but it's so
you're like Jerry Spence the great you
know now I'm not one for you know book
Lorne and but my interest in philosophy
runs elsewhere than its runs further to
past but the goal here is actually
fairly ecumenical and simple and it
doesn't involve deep questions of
philosophy we have a constitution it's
designed to govern us in ways that all
of us can understand and in its place we
have an elaborate scheme in which when
scarcely knows who's producing the law
but has limited input and in which it's
applied to us without judge and jury and
without due process all of which were
designed actually to limit those
guarantees of such things were designed
to limit administrative adjudication so
we're reaching deep into the past of
absolute power and in fact
administrative power is draw ministry
powers drawn from German the German
version of absolute power so this is a
very dangerous game that's being played
and we should be aware of that and need
to fight hit the political scientists
our historian Arthur II Kerch read a
book called the decline of American
liberalism that even in the colonial
period as soon as liberal rights kind of
class
the liberal rights of individualism
autonomy some some means of choosing
among competing versions of life for at
least some portion of the colonists as
soon as those were articulated they you
know power was starting to be
centralized I was it was kind of
disappearing as soon as it was being
said if it's not you know the 1984
Chevron case if it's not you know
Woodrow Wilson is there you know why do
people even bother coming up with a
constitution if immediately they're
gonna start saying no now we're not
going to actually live by the rules that
we just created we're gonna aggregate
more and more power into fewer and fewer
hands right so that's actually precisely
why you have accounts we have a
constitution because we can appeal to it
publicly and in litigation to defend our
freedom and the danger is not someone
else other than ourselves it lies within
us the fibs we tell ourselves and that
the judge is unfortunately I've come to
believe they're all very principled but
they've come but to believe that you
don't really need jury rights when it
comes to administrative hearings you
don't you just did due process is
satisfied by an administrative process
that a rule is no different really than
an enacted statute and so what we need
to do is actually just be honest an
administrative rule is not a statute
adopted by our representatives and it is
not legally binding it's a mere command
a mere edict an administrative
adjudication is not it has no due
process and it's alleged to have a
little bit but it has no due process as
was originally understood due process
comes from the courts it is no jury and
when the judges go out of their way to
accommodate all of this they end up
corrupting their own processes because
they end up being systemically biased
about the long affects what what is to
be done then if the idea of like massing
kind of it are launching massive court
attacks against things to at least stop
these laws from moving forward if that's
not going to work you know what what is
the the best case for it and what what
is the role you know you're a law
professor and what is the role of ideas
here as a
or do we need some kind of horrible
incident where you know finally it shows
how the administrative state is crazy
and out of control right that would be
the Lenin would be happy for that last
no I would prefer something much more
moderate it strikes me that the
executive could begin to pull back on
administrative power whether it will we
have yet to see but I would welcome that
but in the meantime we can do much this
conversation is an opportunity to speak
candidly about the problem and candor is
the essence of the solution and then in
addition that those arguments that are
candid that say direct act that say
accurately what is happening and what
the judges have found themselves to be
doing when they've go down this
dangerous path that could be brought
into litigation not massive litigation
but careful thoughtful litigation that
appeals to the judges best instincts the
judges generally are principled judges
of all sorts and we have to appeal to
their ideals about themselves and show
how they've unfortunately departed from
those ok well we'll leave it there we've
been talking with Philip hamburger he's
a professor at the Columbia Law School
and he is the author most recently of
the administrative threat for reason I'm
Nicholas P
[Music]